good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
thank you for joining us at the
Emergency Response Coordination Center
for a press conference on the
coronavirus President you have the floor
yes thank you so much good afternoon to
all of you first of all I want to
express my full sympathy for those who
are suffering of the corona virus and I
want to thank the medical staff who are
treating them and doing an outstanding
job not only in Europe but all over the
world as you know the corona virus has
brought governments and health systems
throughout Europe to work at all
different levels to contain this virus
and so does the Commission with the
support of our agency the e CDC and in
very close cooperation with the wh old
you witness that from the very beginning
of the outbreak of the corona virus the
European Union has acted we have for
example activated our alert system
immediately we have an ongoing risk
assessment that is being carried out in
close coordination with all the Member
States I think very important is our
European health security committee that
is corroding all these different
national measures so that we have a very
comprehensive approach to contain the
virus we've informed you on a regular
basis over the last weeks about the
support that the Commission provides to
the national authorities in very close
cooperation with the agencies key CDC
has announced today that the risk level
has risen from moderate to high for
people in the European Union in other
word the virus continues to spread
we all know that the many many different
actions that are needed to address
coronavirus are very multifaceted they
are very many fold and since eight weeks
we are working intensively on these
different work strands the Commission
has been addressed all these works
strands we have a situation that is very
complex and it requires on one side very
swift action and on the other side a
strong coordination on all the levels
and all the different sectors not only
on the European level but of course on
the national level and then a very
comprehensive and coherent approach
towards the topic from all 27 member
states and the European Union this is
why today we are launching the corona
response team this Corona response team
brings together all the different
strands of action that have been in
place since many many weeks you have
witnessed their outstanding work but
also brings in place in the corona
response team the new ones the new work
streams the emerging with work streams
the corona response team we have given
you a graph perhaps you move a bit aside
thank you so much you have it here on
the screen and you must have the slide
tool has basically three main pillars
the first pillar is the medical field as
you can see it includes topics from
prevention and procurement there are
relief measures information and
foresight it's always in close
cooperation with ECDC
and our European Medicines Agency the
second big and important column is the
pillar that covers mobility from
transfer to travel advice and also to
the Schengen related questions the third
pillar covers the economy
it is looking in-depth at various
business sectors such as tourism or
transport trade but of course it's
looking also at the value chains and at
the broader macro economic picture we
have to bundle this we also have a
parallel launched today a website under
coronavirus response team where all the
informations we've gathered over all the
weeks and that come on a daily basis are
collected and bundled so that there is a
direct access to the very complex
wide-reaching work the corona response
team is doing you see on the slide tool
that there are other topics that are
presented on the website and worked on
in the corona response team as for
example news press releases calendar
social media statistics which are
important on a daily basis from all over
the different questions that occur in
this scenario the general informations
like access to studies or links to
others the roles and responsibilities
again if you have different questions
that have to be addressed allow me now
to introduce the five commissioners who
will be working together on all these
different different topics it is
Janusz lenarcik who is in charge of
crisis management
it is stella kiriakidis who is in charge
of all the health issues it is in value
Hanson who is in charge of border
related issues
it is Adina Valium who is in charge of
mobility and paolo gentiloni who is
dealing with the macroeconomic aspects
and I would like to invite the different
commissioners now to present their
aspects for the day because this is
situation we're on a daily basis we have
actual news and topics we want to work
on Madame president colleagues
commissioners everybody welcome warmly
to our Emergency Response Coordination
Center I have three points to raise the
dissertation
first on EU response and coordination as
the outbreak intensified a new president
activated the Commission's rapid alert
system and asked me to initiate a
strengthened coordination among our
services for more than a month now in my
capacity as the European emergency
response coordinator he been chairing
regular meetings of the crisis
Coordination Committee to ensure the
overall coordination of all commissioned
services and the European external
Action Service all the services are
fully engaged in monitoring and
supporting efforts to respond to all
facets of this epidemics however
overcoming this challenge also requires
coordination of various decision-making
levels and sectors inside the member
states themselves and that's why we have
called at the last obscure council of
health ministers to introduce
cross-sectoral coordination also inside
their countries my second point is on
preparedness and on contingency planning
what we have learned so far especially
due to what China has been experiencing
is that every country needs to get ready
globalization has left its mark
everywhere why we should not give in to
panic
the situation is likely to still get
worse so we need to be prepared and time
is of essence here that is why we have
focused on preparedness and contingency
measures across policies by supporting
sharing of information assessing the
needs and ensuring a coherent eu-wide
response we based this work on
scientific scientific evidence and
expert recommendations notably from
European center for disease prevention
and control my colleagues will update
you about our efforts to address
ramifications of this outbreak on
healthcare systems and also beyond
affecting certain economic sectors
global supply chains and stock markets
third and my last point is about
solidarity this epidemic is a global
challenge no country can deal with it
alone we need to work together at all
levels from local communities through
member states through digits and
internationally to support global
efforts as you already know the
Commission has mobilized substantial
initial funding of more than 230 million
aro for the World Health Organization
for research and for the pharmaceutical
industry we are looking into further
possible funding in addition our Union
Civil Protection mechanism enables
significant Co finances con financing
and mobilization of offers of assistance
upon request of countries in need then
it is here in this EU Emergency Response
Coordination Center which is working
around the clock
coordinating all collaboration between
civil protection and emergency
departments in member states that we
like our confidence that we will be able
to face this change
thank you very much commissioners the
oculus please Madame president
colleagues ladies and gentlemen as of
this morning we have 2100 confirmed
cases in 18 you member states and we
have 38 citizens who have lost their
lives and I share the president's
condolences to those families affected
we are clearly faced with a rapidly
changing situation last Friday following
the call from member states of the
obscure Council on February 13th we
launched an accelerated joint
procurement for personal protective
equipment in 18 member states we expect
to receive offers within one week and
will proceed in the swiftest way
possible as we speak the European Centre
for disease prevention and Control
publishes the update of its rapid risk
assessment in which they raised the risk
of infection in the EU from low moderate
to moderate to high different member
states face different challenges in
relation to the Kovach 19 outbreak Italy
is facing a situation which is not the
same as other member states it is
however for all an evolving situation
which changes rapidly and we all need to
be ready for further developments as we
had said from the very beginning what is
crucial in facing up to this challenge
is coordination and a comprehensive
approach this is why last Friday I sent
a letter to all EU health ministers
urging them to pay particular attention
to measures for preparedness and
response in the following areas
sufficient resources in the health care
sector for care management sufficient
laboratory capacities for testing
and active contact tracing adequate
Public Health capacities at point of
entry for example at airport and
targeted risk and crisis communication
to the public and health care workers
today and tomorrow I will personally be
in contact with all health ministers
again to share and discuss the ECDC risk
assessment and to discuss our
coordination and to hear their level of
preparedness this will be further
discussed in detail at the EBSCO Council
which will be held on Friday in closing
I would like to say that although this
developing situation is of clear concern
it is not a time for panic or
misinformation fueling more anxiety we
all need to remain calm and focus in
order to get on with the work needed to
fight this disease thank you thank you
very much thank you madam president when
it comes to the borders we have started
a group the coab 819 borders group that
are now have weekly video conferences
this group includes all the Member
States but also the Schengen associated
countries and the frontex European
border and Coastguard Agency and the
Council General Secretariat so far this
conferences has been focusing very much
on how their awareness of the challenges
are the borders and I must tell you that
there is a full and good awareness on
this issue from all the Member States
and they have this close cooperation
together with the health authorities and
this is of course very essential so far
there have been no reported problems
with this coordination with the health
authorities and I can tell you that so
far no member state has
have any indication that I will have an
internal border checks inside the
Schengen area so the work is going on
there has also been some discussions on
the visa mechanism but because of the
time lag for visas I think that is
better to concentrate on the border
crossing points and any measures that
can be taken there Thank You
commissioner volume please president
ladies and gentlemen the coronavirus
crisis at the huge impact on transport
sector as it was expected and it was
from the very beginning this is why from
the very beginning all the eeo transport
services talking about the devotion I'm
talking about the European Aviation
Safety Agency Maritime Safety Agency
European rail agency this shows all
modes where involves from the very
beginning acting monitoring giving
advice coordinating with Member States
and stakeholders to have a very good
look and present image of what is going
on in terms of transport the agency
disseminated all necessary information
such as travel advice on a regular basis
is the beginning of the crisis I'm very
happy that we are going to have a
website so that it will be very easy for
people interested to check in one place
very up-to-date information from our
perspective for passengers they will
have exhaustive information on transport
and coronavirus and will have a clear
overview of the options available
including refunds this is what we are
doing today to prepare the information
for passengers and people in trouble
what travellers should know first and
foremost is that at European level we
have a very robust set of rules for the
passengers rights it is imported
European level and it may apply also to
situations like this one my final word
is that it is absolutely crucial to
maintain the mobility of citizens as far
as possible we need the transport
services to provide regular services
seamless and of course if one at least
to dimension it is for the health
emergency response as I said in the
meantime we continue to liaise with our
stakeholders to quantify also the
financial impact on the transport sector
and I'm sure about this my colleague
Commissioner gentiloni will speak more
on the financial impact thank you and
good morning in presenting our winter
forecast I made clear that the duration
of the outbreak and of the containment
measures represented a key downside risk
what has happened since then first it
has become clear that the short-term
impacts on the Chinese economy is likely
to be significant as the striking drop
in the Purchasing Managers Index data
for February indicates as you know the
index fell to a record low of 35 point 7
from 50 in January moreover spillovers
outside of China have increased over the
past 10 days changing the the picture
sectors affected are mostly tourism
travel
transport automotive high-end fashion
but in general supply chains are in
discussion and raw material import from
China are falling down wind consequences
on global prices and markets in a
nutshell we are seeing the
materialization of these downside risks
the fact that it is still too soon to
measure the impact of this downside
doesn't mean that we can minimize it I
think that the idea of a probable
v-shaped recovery very quick slowing
down and very quickly returning up that
was presented twenty fifteen days ago
can't be given for granted at could
prove optimistic the very situation that
the OECD this morning described in its
forecast is already different as you
know the baseline for OECD is a global
is a global two point for growth a
Chinese four point nine growth and zero
point eight growth for euro area which
is different from what we were
forecasting just a couple of months ago
just to give you an impression because
the baseline of OECD forecast is
reasonable of how strong the economic
impact could prove I want to recall that
our rules incorporate several features
that allow to take an account changing
economic situations including the
possibility for governments to respond
to unusual events we will assess
requests on this basis obviously with a
spirit of solidarity and understanding
in this extraordinary times and finally
we are working I am working the
Commission is working the president is
working to coordinate the reaction
because we need a coordinated reaction
we will meet the Eurogroup will meet
with a teleconference this Wednesday
sharing the immediate measures taken to
react to the outbreak at the same time
we coordinated with the g20 in Saudi
Arabia the necessity to stand ready I am
reading to take further action to
address these risks and we are also in
contact with Minister of Finance of the
g7 to have in in in the next hours or
days a collective response coordinated
collective response to what happens it
is time today to declare that EU is
ready to use all the available policy
options if and when needed to safeguard
our growth against these downside risks
this is time for solidarity it is time
to build confidence it is time to act we
will now open the floor for questions we
take questions naturally on the corona
virus so yes David please there is there
are two moving mics and you should get
hold of one through my
colleagues who are trying to get to you
and please introduce yourself when
asking the question Thank You Danny
David Herzen horn whistle let it go
president underline could you say if the
Commission is considering canceling any
of its meetings or urging the council to
cancel the upcoming new Co summit and
especially the Beijing meeting the
Commission summit with Beijing will that
go forward at this point you know at the
moment being there are no plans of
cancelling but this can always change by
the day I must say at the I cannot say
anything about the Beijing meeting
because there too we have to discuss the
matter with our hosts thank you very
much Sam there is a mic standing mic
here for you thanks Sam Fleming from the
Financial Times
could I follow up on the the economic
comments that you made a commissioner
and annoying and you talked about the
need for coordinated response are you
effectively now suggesting that there
needs to be four countries which have
fiscal space and a fiscal expansion and
could you give us a sense of the agenda
for the conference call on Wednesday
please Thanks well my understanding and
what I discussed with President Centeno
and other minister of China is that the
Eurogroup conference call will be mainly
dedicated to share opinion and
information on the immediate response
the decisions support the health care
systems show a liquidity to firms and
perhaps face timing of that payments
face and employment risks this kind of
measures some countries are already
advanced in taking these measures other
will study them it depends also on the
situation of coronavirus country by
country
then I think we will have a first
discussion on what will be in the agenda
of the Eurogroup in March the 16th which
is the coordinated physical response I
think we should have very clearly in
mind that a coordinated fiscal response
to be very timely you can't take it too
early you can't take it too late so this
will be I think the the issue of the
discussion and it depends also on the
evolution of the outbreak we have
different tools in our fiscal policies
to adopt that we should adopt them at
the right moment and with a large
consensus Thank You Roberto Telesca
Italia Madame president as you know
several countries outside the U more and
more actually are banning the entrance
of European citizens coming from the
area's most affected by the virus do you
think these measures are justified and
if not are you going to use the external
service the diplomacy to do a sort of
moral situation to remove these bans I
think in the case of coronavirus we have
to respect decisions of different
countries in the world it is very much
dependent on where passengers do come
from and what the risk assessment is if
you look at our institutions for example
or if you look at our companies many of
the companies now decide for example to
tell their employees who come from red
zones for example to do telework for two
weeks at home if not showing symptoms
then to come back to work this is on a
very individual basis but they are of
course relating to what the institutions
in the European Union are doing with the
reference with reference to their
employees so I think respect for all the
other countries who
this is their decision and the same goes
for what we decide inside the European
Union Michels Wall Street Journal here
president von der Leyen
about member states in coordination
policies towards things like gatherings
vary greatly among member states France
has taken a very severe approach to it
and Germany is taking a much more
relaxed approach can and should there be
more coordination and standardization of
policies on this issue
thank you there is an enormous amount of
coordination I've been witnessing since
the last eight weeks outstanding
commissioner Elena church and
Commissioner kiriakidis who are mainly
dealing with that topic when it comes to
the different actions of member states
so what you have not seen is the high
level of coordination because then there
is no difference and it's not obvious
invisible to you I think the decision
the the local regional of federal
decision governmental decision on for
example at what point should meetings be
canceled is to be respected because of
course it depends a lot on what is the
situation in the respective member state
who is the audience that is coming to
this meeting and in what kind of area
are we so therefore it is to be
respected and I want to emphasize again
there has been a huge amount of
coordination over the last eight weeks
the result you can track on the website
with all the information that is done
there
next question here good morning
president alligoon a volunteer platter
Spanish purse Spain had last year six
thousand three hundred debt uncommon
great don't you think this is a
saturating situation regarding the
figures one question and second question
right could you please speak up a bit
yes
Spain had six thousand three hundred
people dead uncommon great last year
you're talking about flu pain when you
think regarding the figures about the
this virus is a bit saturating situation
in the world first question second don't
you think this is a inside a commercial
war between USA and China the second
question was this is that result the
result I do not commit that would result
of a trade war between not at all I do
think that what the virus itself is
concerned being a medical doctor I rely
heavily on the experts opinion these are
the epidermal epidemiologists these are
the public health experts the biologists
who are experts on that topic and as I
said being a medical doctor I learn a
lot from them indeed of course if we go
into comparison with the winter flu we
have their large numbers of infections
and the death toll is it a certain level
but what but what we did let's test the
other mic
perhaps this one is getting better but
what we should not underestimate is the
fact that is it better for you okay
better yes so the point that I would
emphasize it's a new type of virus we
there's a lot we do not know of course
we are aware of the fact that there are
different types of infections sometimes
without any symptoms sometimes with mild
symptoms and as you know sometimes with
very severe symptoms the virus is
spreading very fast so all these topics
have to be taken into account and I
think it is absolutely plausible and
acceptable that we have a cautious alert
vigilant attitude towards the spreading
of the virus because as I've said it's a
completely new one and I recommend that
we listen to the majority of the experts
see masala press African madam president
who's Julia kalkaluru on Africa
disappear Adela Morales Nalepa Danny
total melodic scale comment no s dozen
SP 70 who's ever disputed question as a
important having vocalic de la comisión
de linear african-america vocally the
corona response team s constrictor Vasu
tip you see the logic porno Bakunin
arrive at the Supply Co console Connery
avocation development economist Pulido
nobility valkira Conte de la situación
Colonel on stone asset Ola la semaine
dernière honor God OS key concern a
corona virus at the moment there was one
single case and that one was in Egypt so
this was approximately a week ago
therefore it has been touched but more
in the way that I reported from the
situation that is takes place at the
moment being shown on a stone on the web
as key concern Parker Luna African at
Toulon WA the the the upon the immediate
mobius ooh
communism head coach collaboration with
some total of the faculty the nose
experience Sakana Fedya confer Ameerpet
la prochaine fois pascal on the back
risotto 1280 nelly Comedy Tour the
mistakes mercy laser canapa tetra favor
Lee Park on a fete : moon may come you
know African Le Coq let maka pablor
detailee of some mechanism may do some
to play the donee thule experience con -
woman yeah Kalavati 18 Cronos italy it's
just two questions one forum
Commissioner Valley on its own transport
because many airlines have canceled
flights are concerning flights on a
daily basis because of a drop in demand
you said that the EU rules apply for
embarrassment does this mean that the
passengers who get direct flights
conserved are entitled also to get the
compensation of 250 for 400 euros per
flight or not and the second question
for commissioner gentlemen if I may the
Italian government announced a package
of 3 billion something to help the
distressed areas I wonder if you're
ready to give this flexibility to the
government and if you think that it will
be enough thank you yes some passengers
right in the event of cancellation which
happens of course of course the first
thing for the airline says to reroute
and reimbursed the question of
compensation it's a separate one here of
course passengers would have the right
to a compensation if the cancellation if
they were not informed about the
constellation with at least 14 days
before the departure
yet compensation is not to do if the
cancellation even at short notice it's
caused by extraordinary circumstances
which could not have been avoided even
if all reasonable measures had been
taken and there is a discussion that the
coronavirus
situation might fall under this case so
the outbreak of coronavirus the house
related reasons could fall generally
under this exemption yet the assessment
is made on case-by-case basis and
ultimately under the authority of the
Court of Justice of the European Union
we're so sorry calling that the new
legislation on passengers rights do not
does not cover the situation where
passengers decide decide voluntarily to
give up on travel to renounce to a
flight for example or to any other
transport service that is regularly
operated and here this is on contractual
basis between the traveler and the
company and it has to be according to
the commercial rules enforced in a way I
think this answers the question thank
you very much well as you know know as
you know the now rules we have the
disclose of concerning unusual events
sure Costanza it's generally in Italian
and and we will consider the Italian
requests which is for sure based on
these extraordinary circumstances and we
will consider this as I said with in
spirit of solidarity and understanding
of the situation where we are so I think
that this is my positive answer as far
as the amount is concerned I think it's
a proportionate response to the
emergency but I imagine that Italy and
other countries will
to face both emergency issues and more
long and medium term problems but this
is at the time not for the Commission to
discuss at least not for single
countries but only on the aggregate
level
thank you very much Don Corona
is Virginie the acoustics Don health
Basu was a very cozy taiz to clay Mazda
Manavi existed oxidation on our
regulation digital non-arab utopian
fidelity mofesto carniverous
s-curve of a precision approach the
demands demand existent or Audrey
caçapava trees a document you can manage
cetera the Tecla monk
the way I play out Lisette - sook -
laser till Kanna poor fellows a sad
situation ill for a low fare down low
mama ooh la necessity Sarah la pluie
Claire say trade officials led Apple a
lame Ezreal extraordinaire
don't entropic repeted logo the maitre d
case compare the reserve the blue long
term on at the dissection plot extreme
the secona decided on Lukas finishes the
DeMille width may just Romana Rapala
honor impossibility the world they
measure through diferencia entre
different page that should
little reserves on the filter physical
space on to our sister work Latrese in a
difficult economy difficult a keeper via
the dakota Dola Dola Dola demand
educated the loss etc and police follow
mama in difficulty from the supply-side
s fa la la upon fiscal by exhaustive for
one response meant response fiscal
Milosevic a certain difficulty came
alone let's apply Alamo l leizerman y la
demence
laquelle la política fiscal path turkey
in further response coordinator awaken
politic fiscal policy supportive
Sebastian do Francis supportive and if
supported many the difference on top a
pseudo general is a set or pawns do at
this day the only person do trust man
Ellis no solution the resolution case
laugh estonian public broadcasting at
behind i wanted to follow up the
possibility of economic help you already
mentioned that concerning supply problem
it's harder to do anything is there
anything at all actually you could do to
help it and you mentioned that the level
of risk has rising in you is there at
some point you consider losing some
regions or borders or is it absolutely
not not the topic no this is not under
consideration and it's not us who have
said that the risk is risen
has risen but it's the ECDC so we are
very much relying on the experienced
agency we do have that monitor on the
hourly basis the development and have a
lot of experience how to deal with
disease prevention and preventing the
spread of infectious diseases so here we
are really relying on the experts on the
economy I think Commissioner
gentiloni said many many things if he
wants if he wishes to add something he's
welcome but I think he provided the
answers for all facets on the economy
Davidge a little in the back thank you
proceed upon the line
you said that the coordination is the
key right now but if you look at the
response by the different new member
states we we cannot see coordination in
Belgium we have some measure I would say
quite liberal in Italy other measures in
France other even between European
institution I can access here but I
cannot access for example at the
European Parliament if I'm functional
civil servant of the European Parliament
because yesterday I was in Veneto so but
not in the red zone so I'm following the
rule by the different it's quite
difficult for so what's the problem on
on that and the second question if I may
- Commissioner kiriakidis you have said
that the situation in Italy is different
from other countries all other countries
do you think that more controls or a top
Schengen freedom of movement would be
wise right now since for example this
six cases today in Belgium all comes
comes from Italy thank you
so very briefly from my side because
it's once again commissioned I tell you
at heaters who's the expert in it I've
witnesses over the last as we eight
weeks a huge amount of coordination and
you you touched upon a few questions yes
there's a difference between the
European Parliament of the European
Commission only what travelers from the
yellow zones in Italy is concerned
otherwise we're completely on the same
page what what the actions we are taking
are concerned but there's a huge
coordination not only between this 27
member states and their respective
regions but of course with the World
Health Organization and the the e CDC on
what measures have to be taken what we
do not see all the many many work
strands that function where a total we
have complete coordination because
thanks but there are no differences
there are no problems so they are not
visible and with that I would really
like to give the chance to the
Commission actually this was done an
outstanding work on on these health
issues together with Janish where are
you on this topic over the last eight
weeks and perhaps you might at the very
end once again say something to the
coordination of the crisis management
first of all I'd like to say two words
under coordination and your point that
different member states seem to be
taking different measures but as I said
from the very beginning the situation
concerning curb it 19 is not the same in
all the Member States and this is
evident also from the EC DC and whu-oh
region Europe assessments we have had
saying this we have coordinated and with
all Member States that they all have
their level of preparedness in place so
that with the rapidly evolving situation
you should be able to adjust to what
what measures you are taking but it
would not be I think possible for them
to be all taking the same exact measures
when we have member states which so far
do not have cases and we have others
which have which have evolved in cases
so it is a daily day
a day-to-day readjustment but the
important thing is that we are
coordinating what everybody is doing
what needs to be done in this changing
situation as for the situation that you
mentioned with Italy in the Europe at
the moment we're at the point of of
containment containment means that what
we are doing is early diagnosis contact
tracing and following up from that zone
so each member state has their action
plans in place and they decide according
to their situation what measures they
should be taking thank you just to add
very quickly one has to distinguish
between coordination and in position but
there is a part of the website roles and
responsibilities but you will find the
details about the responsibilities so at
this point let me just say the following
on most of these issues the Commission
has a coordinating and supportive role
but the responsibility for measure stake
lies with the Member States health
interests on other issues what we try to
do is we try to keep information flow so
that everybody knows what the other is
doing we try to we try to issue the
recommendations but ultimately is the
decision of the membership yes they
differ but why do they differ because as
commissioner kirakira said situation is
different in different member states but
we believe that the measures to be taken
to be take to be taken need to be
proportionate need to be relevant for
the situation locally and therefore the
state yes there are questions like why
don't we ban travel close the borders
these are harsh measures but the
effectiveness of them is questionable so
in short I think that all measures that
have to that need to be taken fair to
the sound and based on scientific
evidence need to be proportionate and
taken in a coordinated manner
thank you that's very logical questions
from two very patient colleagues first
of all the colleague from today F and
then Maria here yeah
good night crickets at a German
television here just two questions to
president funny line how can you give
further support to Greece to Greece and
Bulgaria try to use the motto
try it again it's on now how can you
give further support to two big area
so our priority is to give Bulgaria and
Greece all the necessary support they
need and handling the situation on the
ground because the challenge that Greece
is facing right now is a European
challenge and therefore tomorrow I will
travel together with jean-michel and dub
it's a solely so the representatives of
the three three European institutions to
Greece visit the Prime Minister and
together with him after consultation
visit the border area to assess on the
ground what can be increased what the
support is concerned yesterday afternoon
the Greek authorities asked increased
support from front chicks and triggered
the so called a rapid border
intervention mechanism or intervention
team in other words which we are working
very closely now Frank Frontex is
working very closely with the other
member states to provide border guards
and equipment for front checks to bring
it to Greece and to support their the
Greek authorities and the second part of
your question is well I acknowledge that
Turkey is in a difficult situation
concerning the with regards to the
refugees and the migrants but what we
see now cannot be an answer or solution
therefore we establish a more and more
intensive dialogue with Turkey through
all different political levels to first
of all find again common ground what the
situation for the refugees in Turkey is
concerned and to discuss where support
might be needed knowing that we do have
an agreement in place
where
we stick to and which we think is the
right basis to start the dialogue within
the next days commissioner Leonard Ridge
will go to Gaziantep or the area of
Gaziantep or to look there what can be
done as support also for the difficult
situation of the refugees which are
between Italy and the Turkish border
what humanitarian aid is concerned -
thank you very much very last question
from Maria please keep it short we're
over the time the same topic is
president and re-refer with hearing news
first of all who is going on behalf of
the Commission there besides you and
what's the political support that the
Commission can provide to Greece and and
second question how would you answer to
all these speculations saying that the
Greek people was left alone were left
alone during the weekend defending the
European border so first of all there is
tomorrow to answer your first question
tomorrow
the represented tomorrow that we present
this is a good idea
thanks yeah so
this yeah tomorrow the representatives
of the three European institutions the
Parliament the council and the
Commission that is president Davidson
solely presidential Michelle and me
we're going together to Greece to show
the full support of the European Union
as I said the challenge Greece is facing
is a European challenge and Greece has
our full support over the last days
there has been a lot of support on the
front tech side and of course the
ongoing support for Greece in the
refugee camps in Greece itself as I said
Greece triggered and this is rightly so
the rabbit mechanism which is important
to bring additional border guards and
additional equipment to that what is
already in place in Greece and of course
whatever is needed as special measures
or help we are very open to respond and
we are in close cooperation I've been in
contact all these days with several
phone calls per day with the Greek Prime
Minister to support and to coordinate as
much as possible in this evolving
situation thank you thank you very much
have a good afternoon
[Music]
you